I'm Jason number five of seven here
which i think is cool
so time travel to bugging time travel
debugging is a really old concept but
it's also been a multi-year project in
Mozilla and most recently a six-month
sprint to this stage so if you see
something you like please clap let me
know I want to hear it if you really
like it shout if you're moved by it just
come up in clap I do real-time claps I
can keep going so here's the debugger my
name is Jason Laster and I have the
privilege to work full time on this
country it's great most recently we made
this decision to rewrite it in actually
react and redux which has been a really
amazing opportunity to rethink a lot of
things were doing and do some really new
things that are great - is there an echo
or is it just me
okay one thing we did was we moved to
github and started doing local
development as a website so we can start
it up with web pack and yarn and then
click that button or other buttons for
Chrome a note find a Firefox and debug
it
as a website not as a browser and that's
been amazing for working on and you just
like refresh and you got everything new
and your debug and and if you want to
debug that you've got a browser debugger
no problem
and while we're working on it maybe we
used from' but like you know just on the
side it's a website you can do whatever
you want to do we focus on two things
recently and we're gonna carry this out
for the next year or two one of them is
frameworks because we realize that so
many people are building modern apps
with frameworks and there's so much we
can do to make debugging better if you
use them and babble so I've got stickers
with me for the tc39 because we work
closely with a JavaScript team and
stickers for Babel because we work just
as closely with them because we know
that people who are writing apps today
are often using things like JSX and flow
and typescript and new language features
that can't be parsed by the Firefox
parser like you won't even want to those
are different things and Apple has been
amazing we've worked closely with that
team and we've added features that would
not have been possible otherwise like
breakpoints that stay in your function
when you change your code so you don't
have to move them or when you step in
the code you wrote the original code it
just works even though you're stepping
over like 10 lines of generated code
it's really really amazing and I think
in part because we are in react and web
developers can work on it and we're in
github and we are on Twitter we've found
this amazing community of people who
want to work on their tools that they
use every day and if you are interested
in hacking on developer tools I want to
say that I have never found a team more
open to open source than the Firefox dev
tools team so come join us and work on
the debugger or work on the inspector or
their console we really want that in
fact we kind of need it for like 10 12
people it's really really small and
almost everything you see is a product
of the great work in the community and
they've done wasm and search amazing
tests and flow types because those
things help the community our tooling
comes from the community we wouldn't
have it otherwise and I am so grateful
for the team that has come and joined us
in a helped mentor their Charter is to
help newcomers get started and so the
questions like why does that work that
way how do I get yarn working or no
they're here to help people come in and
they love as much as we do so huge thing
for them many of them are here now and
you guys will rock y'all
yes
so debugging we're done right like we've
done it like it's us all from sure I
kind of have this belief that in some
ways it's gotten worse because their
apps have gotten so much better and
maybe our tools haven't caught up and
we're still kind of playing computer and
at the end the day maybe a good night's
sleep is all you need so there's more to
do even a simple feature like a heart
let's say you want to like click the
heart and you want to see it hardened
can we heart the heart even that can be
difficult today you click it and nothing
happens why well a lot of things have to
happen for the heart to be hearted
generally speaking there's this whole
path for updating the data gotta get the
UI data you gotta talk to the API you
gotta get that data from the API update
the store and once the stores up-to-date
we can update the UI but it can break at
any point along the way and you can add
all the logs you want or pause it any
step you're gonna have to understand the
system and maybe it's gonna take a while
the thing I'm most excited the one
takeaway for this whole talk is with
time travel we have a full recording of
time which means we can show you this
thing this thing right here and if you
want to you can step to any point you
can jump to any point in the path and
see it immediately you don't have to
refresh or we click or pause or look at
the logs we can just give it to you so
it opens up all these opportunities that
are now possible but time travel is not
a new thing
others have done it I remember when Dan
Abramov showcased Redux and not so long
though and I think at JJ's County you
and he says some every stuck with me he
wanted time travel
and so he wanted to reduce his actions
over time but he wanted time travel and
the demo is just crazy you can get this
slider that shows you all the actions
over time and then as you're moving you
can see the UI update
it's just perfect it's magical it's
exactly how you want to develop but it
only works if using redux and it only
shows you the Redux actions it's not
full time travel there's other tools
Cypress which is an amazing integration
test tool which makes it easy and in
fact fun to write integration tests and
they have this reporter on the left that
shows you things that change over time
so you can mouse over the reporter and
for each action see the UI update which
is brilliant you get it before and after
but again it's only the UI and yes it's
amazing they do amazing work you should
try it so how do we do a general purpose
thing the good thing is that we already
have about 10 years ago
Mozilla invest in the culture parar
which is full recording and fast replay
for C and C++ and this thing which is
now used quite a lot gives you that
ability to sift through time it's fast
because if making the recording is slow
you're not gonna use it if we winding it
slow you may reach for if you need to
but you might not and it goes down to
the kernel it knows about the OS and
Soompi trays and s tray so it has more
time I like they keep so that makes it
Universal as well once you have all that
data it can run for Firefox acre run for
Chrome it could even run for arbitrary C
or C++ programs it just works and you
can use it to reproduce things it's
really really cool the problem is what
if your application has non determinism
what if it's something like the browser
that every time you use a could be
different well about five years ago this
project for web replay came out which
said this our our thing is great for the
platform but can we give it to web
developers
yeah I just love that animation it
serves no purpose but it's fun and
amazingly I've been using web replay and
it's fast the recordings do not slow
down the browser that much and we're
still using the system recording and get
all the data so it's as deep as you want
to go but because Firefox is complicated
that she sees complicated just
complicated networking of complicated
API is layout is madness it's tied to
Firefox it's not gonna easily be
portable Chrome
even though we would like to work with
AMI so but that comes a risky part let
me show you what we've got so at the
moment I've got a custom builder Firefox
over here and I'm not gonna update it
quite yet so that's my tab I think
that's gonna work
got the color picker cool over here and
web developer the record execution I
don't think it has to stay in a context
menu but for now it is and once I do
that I've started a record for us us so
everything that happens here every click
by the way this is like a fun color
picker I'm a select colors and keeps
them everything's now recorded what does
that mean well let's see here I've got
some code for some demos I'm gonna set a
directory routes and focus in on the
code were working on find the index and
now I've got some code we've got an
outline of you were already told you
babbles amazing these things just like
start happening once you introduce
babble like really cool features find
the circle component set a breakpoint at
some JSX and we paused that's great so
in some ways time travel web replay is
the most simple feature that's gonna be
shown because we've just added some
buttons it's the same debugger that you
know but now we can step back just like
you said forward and
yeah we can rewind so let's say there's
some bug with the way the wheel was
working and or we just don't like blue
we can hit that rewind button and now
we're gonna get in your color and for
fine we're gonna do to do no I don't
like that one I want this one yeah no
this one yeah that's good
I hope the color contrast is enough for
you to see like that's green that's
changing and I'm gonna set a conditional
breakpoint here to get the name of the
color and I type this right I want to
pause at the last time we were below and
I'll rewind and there we are that is now
possible
what was the first time we went blue
let's get the other way - I like that
just as much sweet you know small
sidetrack just for a minute I promise
we've been working on this other thing
for the past three months that I'm
really excited about and I'm just gonna
show that to you quickly - so this code
has this function get HSL yeah it takes
the color shows the HL h SL valium
I wrote this function in a utils file
over here let's find that you chose yes
get HSL and i can go to console I can
type it and over here in the module I
can see it everything just works but
that's not the native behavior it would
be if we were using es modules heus
modules are amazing it just works but
this was a react app built with web pack
and the default behavior for web pack
and frankly with a lot of babel plugins
is you get this different blocks for DIF
Kotick what's that what's that what's
this jeaious thing ooh boy we heard -
tab function Yoho
I don't know yeah right here okay cool
so we don't want that this this is what
you want anyways I just want to give a
shout out because we've worked with
Logan Smith on the babel team for the
past five months and he's done amazing
work
we're actually parsing the files using
source maps to map it up and magic that
probably should never have worked but
Logan is a genius and he knows the
internal of the transforms and source
maps so who goes to him
demo number two oops no good talk can
avoid to do MPC it's so good and frankly
I have to do MBC open almost every
single day because that's what I deposit
it's great it works so clear that rude
will go in here find some JavaScript set
a new room voila some-some shy yes and
it's backbone and I love it so we set a
breakpoint over here boom how many
people did backbone development back in
the day yeah that was that that was
great that was this [ __ ] that was I
loved it
it's where I got started backbone was
like a bring your own render function
library don't worry about it and I just
took it for granted and it was great but
thinking about this demo I saw this
render function I was like really what
is it even doing I mean really come on
and I started looking at it I was like
huh I'm gonna look at it more closely
maybe one go back here and check that
out or where's this like why are we
toggle visible that's like custom code
anyone look at that and step in is
hidden hmm okay we're gonna like
actually manipulate the checkbox right
now fine
in render I don't even care what's this
doing which is to JSON okay we're just
here lies some data and then we will go
the template the thing I love about this
and I get that yeah we're gonna go back
oh because it's on the same line nice
maybe this no no going well I can always
like step back and jump in right yes
templates with data amazing debugging
with time travel is about exploring the
entire
space but it's also about looking at one
complicated function and not being
afraid to step forward because you can
always go back so I wanted to show that
and maybe I'll just close this recording
and start a new one yeah no that's name
I'm sorry yeah no I mean yeah but all
right fine whatever focus I'm going to
save this close it yeah you see what's
coming right don't you want to check out
used to do as we created right yeah we
don't have the ability to set a
breakpoint yet and open dev tools but
that's coming and yes that's exciting
that's my favorite emoji
all right so there are four things I
want to show you that are not really
live demo Bowl and we got a move
so exceptions by the way with a Sanders
talk this morning on exceptions amazing
god that was so cool
yes we all know him we all love them we
all hate when we get them and we don't
know why and we're not really sure what
to do well time travel right that thing
oh that thing is interesting maybe I'll
look at the call stack no that doesn't
only help me I'm gonna click that link
at index and rewind to that spot where
it happened ready yes yes yes yeah
that's what you want you want to figure
out why it was called that where I fit
was Claud with the wrong names and now
you can what about production right like
this is this is the money if we can help
you debug your production app that's
getting hundreds of exceptions oh that
would be good and if you forget about
the privacy thing like if you're not
working in Bank of America we might just
be able to turn this on by default
at which point that error now comes with
a recording you can download that
recording and there you are
what about failing tests who has
intermittence I want empathize raise
your hand if you got intermittent really
intermittent Sorek test fail like 1% of
time and their haunted by them and you
don't know why they happened like that
could never happen I wrote this
perfectly no there is conditions the
killer feature in the short term is to
be able to debug intermittence so
whenever there's something that happens
that surprises it you've got that same
recording to pull it down and maybe
you've got a happy case in the sad case
and you can just compare them maybe ask
the computer to do it
alright logs the thing I hear having
worked on a debugger for two years more
than anything and it drives me nuts is
an apology everyone comes up to means
like oh yeah your debugger is cool
debugger to cool but I don't use it I
should cuz like the good developers use
it I wish I were one but I just use
prints Damon in fact I talked a lot of
really senior engineers in the wreck I
just use a console they're not even
apologize and they were like that's what
I do and there's some truth to the fact
that when you pause and when you're
stepping it can be a little slower and
sometimes you just want that full
history so there should be a way to kind
of marry them end with time travel by
the way this is a real bugged I had for
three months when you hover on a
variable you want to show the preview
but it's really hard to know if you're
hovering on the variable and then the
pop-up or off so you had tons of logs
added tons of odds 3-month bug finally I
found it I know able to click on the
console log message and go into the
debugger and see what the [ __ ] was going
on and that's time travel it's like
Alexa at some point you're like Alexa I
want to go back in time and then you
were doesn't have it I'm using dev
edition I'm using nightly uh I gotta go
there whatever it just be gonna reach
for it and it makes it easier just to do
what you want to do so that's number one
Redux we rebuilt the debugger to use
react and redux I wanted time-travel you
can kind of see that that's something
that I'm into and on the right you see
that we're using the Redux dev tools and
awesome it shows a full list of all the
actions for the debugger at a nit we get
sources we get paws action we show the
paws data all that stuff here is Redux
dev tools hooked up with time travel so
dev tools shows us the state of the app
the UI as for important time and when I
finally want to jump into the debugger I
just come and click and wait for word
wait for word maybe I'm gonna find the
pause thing yeah right there boom now we
have the - one on top of the other and
you can get the best out of both you
don't just have to see the Redux state
you can actually see the code behind it
that fired up and you can just jump
forever
nice this demo is kind of fabricated cuz
I don't want to get the Redux dev tools
thing in but you get the point
UI so you don't just have to debug your
JavaScript to use the recording you can
recording everything at this point so
why not look at the DOM and how often
have you rendered this case where a
website you're working on has some
loading interaction and maybe CNN drives
you nuts because it flashes and you're
not sure why it's probably images coming
down videos loading CSS you name it so
we've got the net monitor we have the
inspector and now with time travel we
have two ways to pause you can say pause
at the time when this stylesheet loaded
or pause at the time that the layout
changed and that's amazing right because
you can see the before and after and you
can just see the comparison all this
stuff frameworks yeah all right two
things here one with react when you
pause in a render with react 16 you
don't know why you plus in fact you
don't know where your pause you know
you're in a component but why what's the
parent
what's the whole componentry well we've
been working on this framework feature
so we can show you the tree in your claw
stack which is useful but unfortunately
because it's a sink we can't actually
let you go back to that render and and
see it because it sort of happen it's
done
and so yeah time travel boom boom it's
now possible again it just works as
you'd want to so anything that's async
and frameworks are going async and
scheduling is now recoverable you have a
set timeout
you got some async frames below it can't
see them you can your paused in a render
because of a redux action that fired we
can figure out that the reason we're
paused is Redux and we can put down the
call stack and again boom you're in the
action or so you're in the reducer and
if you want to you can rewind to the
action
all right how much time but I feel like
that's just the beginning there's so
much we can do at this point and we
haven't scratched the surface it's
almost like we're used to debugging
paper maps and we want Google Maps we
can build in the whole path and
visualize that you can jump around in
fact we could build a video player and
you can scrub yeah I love that animation
and before I finish I just want to say
that having join was another two years
ago I've realized how special place it
is Netscape opened sourcing Netscape in
the browser in many ways created the
world we live in now with open source at
scale investing in the web investing and
rust because if you're gonna build a
fast browser you need paralyzation
investing in our ten years ago because
if you have paralyzation you're gonna
need to be able to debug it has helped
create the world that we live in now and
I see us potentially pulling this off as
an experiment we don't know if it's
gonna happen but it could so thank you